[Music]
it's not a free-agent destination
they're not going to be in the market
Charlotte for a list guys if you're the
Charlotte Hornets is letting go of Kimba
going to be beneficial for you if he
goes it's like starting over the
community loves Kemba Walker he does
things the right way
he's a leader he is the perfect guy to
lead your franchise I'm just a team
player I'm having fun teammates when
they do great things you know I'm just
happy yeah that's who I am
it's all about how Charlotte builds
around him Campbell Walker like he's
developed into an all-star he's always
been as swar chemists rific I love what
he planned everybody's always plotted
against them becomes the play every
night the Charlotte Bobcats select
Kemble
we're here with Kemba Walker who's
getting a whole lot of attention pretty
solid rookie year concentrate Mia so far
through the first half of the season
pretty well I'm just trying to get
better
no everyday
[Music]
I really think they can build around
temple walk I think he is that good he's
including that much he is that dynamic
it's a lot easier to build when you've
got something to build with the
foundation Kemble is their foundation if
I'm Charlotte I don't know that I wanna
use that guy
do the grass through this much film a
walker Charlotte's all-time leading
scorer you know I gotta I gotta bring it
every day I gotta bring it every night
you know I have to be on point each and
every night with my leadership as I go
about my team and go I don't know what's
going on behind closed doors they're
probably considering you know some sort
of rebuild Charlotte is a little bit
more of a sensitive market
Kemba Walker really good player in his
prime is reportedly available
I'm not as big or you know athletic as
those other guys you know my heart is
definitely one of the things that gave
me over to help with my passion for the
game when you get hot like that the
great players continue to stay on
they're rolling keep punting they're
shot because they know they can have a
special night Kimbo got hotter like
for deserting a lot of time with the
third and I'm the tough guy have 58 out
of the timeout
you know where the ball is going he
wants that moment he's been watering
this stage
he's remarkable
he has going
got every shot to beat you up what's
going in I just think rebuild is where
they are because this team is not
meeting their expectations I put my
heart and soul into this team and into
the city so I'm gonna do everything for
the third time he's an all-star but for
the first time he has heard his name
called as a starter making third team as
we talked about means Walker is eligible
to be paid as much as 221 million
dollars by the Hornets it's kind of
surreal you know I had a lot of doubt
coming into my early career about just
even being the elite point guard in this
league
I think the Lakers would love to have
Walker in their lineup
Kemba Walker he would fit in like Stukas
man you could put the ball in his hands
but how do you say no to 80 million if
you're kimba I think New York would be a
good option but I could see that
happening I mean I've been there for the
last several years and it was a place
where I got my opportunity to place
where I got my start you've done all the
right things a big
feel this is the place to be for the
rest of his career this is the business
of basketball in all likelihood Kyrie is
headed out of Boston
maybe there's another point guard out
there
Howard Campbell work as potential option
for the Celtics
no teams have interest in doing stuff
like that
Campbell Walker's time with the Hornets
appear to be over and moments ago
Walker agreed to sign a four year back
loan contract to join the boss and
develop
like I said in the past I've gave the
whole position everything I've had every
single night
tom was up there I'm excited I'm excited
I'm happy I made this decision Team
USA's practice exactly once they do have
the components which is good guard play
like I said Kemper Walker's you know an
All NBA player there's four Boston
Celtics here okay Marcus smart jaylen
Brown Jason Tatum and then Kevin Walker
they're trying to like built like a
little training camp and have some
camaraderie as an athlete what more can
you really want oh I'm excited to
finally get things started and enrolled
in I'm terrible so I read this place of
Kyrie coming there being a champion
so that leadership different timbres
want to come and say guys how we
we're going to connect now nothing gets
with the celibacy
right away I've always played to win not
just 11 continue to do hit play to win
you know make the right plays
boy he put the cookie
Gables
minutes
76ers will win their first season
openers no I just wanted to always get
better we got to play better you got to
play it better I got to play it better
stiffs up dudes out there that you
really can't do nothing with you know
they got too much in their bag nothing
went when everybody thinks oh no the
Boston Celtics tape think of you know a
winning culture he could dribble and you
got the calendars he got all the babes
and he needs a hybrid like he has a
motor so it's tough to stop a guy like
that once he gets aboard
Charlotte's all I know I'm gonna say hey
is the city in the organization that
I've been a part of a is the
organization that gave my first up and
some we need to
go from a boy to a man in this league no
Charlotte you know the places I love
very much ready to start a new chapter
so he's super excited to be in a winning
culture to learning franchise while
you're walking into the bandages and
stuff like that and know you want to win
yeah great penetration as kids are
showing us tonight so I got a chance to
be one of these as well so that made it
even more special I'm able to you know
put some more energy into the defensive
end know which is which is great which
we're gonna need each and every night I
really want to be a know high level
you'll be team but I'm super super
excited to represent the city
dispensation it's gonna be exciting it's
gonna be fun
gonna try my best to put on the show for
the city